The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So,
shall we start, as always,
just open for questions.
About any topic.
I listed again trusses,
1-D finite elements,
grad, div, curl.
And I should have
squeezed in x+iy too,
as the magic trick for finding
solutions to Laplace's equation
in 2-D. So those are all
certainly topics that are
in this part of the course.
We didn't really get to
3-D, I'm sorry about that,
where the curl comes in.
Maybe I can say a few
words about curl today.
Anyway, questions.
Discussion.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Ooh, let's see.
So A^T A for a truss.
That's a good question.
Trusses, A^T A. I guess I don't
know any magic tricks either,
so one way is to construct
A, or A transpose,
and then just multiply.
A second way to do it would be
by the four by four bar element
matrices, so go bar by bar.
So four by four bar
matrices, four by four.
So those are already in
the A transpose A form.
They're little A element,
A bar transpose A, jeez,
this isn't a great
as it should be.
A element, but I don't
know if that would be,
so and then you pop those
into their correct places.
I don't think I know any
great idea beyond that.
I think you should really be
ready to construct a matrix A,
yeah.
For a reasonably small
truss, of course.
And of course the
other part of trusses,
the fun part is to be able to
recognize solutions to Au=0.
Possibly by looking at the
truss more than by solving Au=0.
Yeah, any particular example?
Of a truss that I should look
at just to pin this down?
Any favorite trusses?
There was an exam question, what
was it, a complicated truss?
Let's just create a truss.
And just think about it.
Maybe I won't create the whole
matrix A. Here's a truss.
How's that for a truss?
So it's got-- And let me
put no supports on it.
Just, there's a
truss to think about.
Probably we won't get
to all the gory details
but if you look at that
truss, what's the shape of A?
Shape of the matrix A. I
have a row for every bar.
So one, two, three, four, five.
And how many columns
have I got, how many
unknown u's, unknown
displacements have I got?
Eight.
Two four, six, eight.
So I would expect Au=0
would probably have how many
independent solutions?
Three.
You don't know the exact
rank, that's exactly true.
There could be more
than three, right.
So to really pin
it down you'd have
to be sure you were
right about that.
So three, at least.
And I guess here you could tell
me the three solutions to Au=0.
Three rigid motions.
I could translate it to the
right, I could translate it up,
and you would know
what the u is,
so u translating to the right
would be [1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1,
0], right?
That's horizontal motion
all the same, rigid motion.
And we should certainly
discover that if we created A
for this truss,
that Au was zero.
And similarly vertical motion
and the third one would be?
Rotation, rotation.
Yeah.
So if I did the rotation
around there, for example,
this guy would-- this u
would also be a [1, 0] here.
This wouldn't move.
So I'm putting in the four
pieces that would go into u.
This one, what would be the
u for this, the displacement
of that corner of the truss?
In a rotation?
So my rotation is just swing
this whole thing around.
Zero? [0, -1], I think.
Right.
Because it's not
going to go out,
it's going to go
straight down, [0, -1].
And what do you think this
guy is? [1, -1], let's see.
It's going to go
this way, so it's
going to go forward and down.
And I think you're right.
One and negative one, yeah.
I think that would be right.
Yeah, then the truss,
we could check each bar.
That bar, for example,
should not change length
because the movement is
perpendicular to the bar
and I'm writing
ones, but I really
should write some much smaller
number like .1 everywhere,
or something just so that
this isn't a very big angle.
And it wouldn't change
length to first order.
So that that's maybe an example
where we see the motions,
but we didn't actually
create A, and we should
be able to create A,
don't let me prevent you
from thinking about A. Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Should those be ones,
or should they be
root two over twos?
PROFESSOR STRANG: Well,
that's a good question
and after many years I've
figured out that they're ones.
But it's a very good question.
Let's just see why.
Let's look at this bar to
be sure it's not stretched.
Right?
So this guy is moving over
by one, and this also by one,
is my claim.
And then this movement
down doesn't stretch it
to first order, yeah.
So I needed to make
those guys the same.
I guess what I figured out is
that if you're rotating around
here, then somehow it's the
x and y, is that-- Anyway.
Whatever.
So that gives us a chance
to do a specific example.
OK, but I've dodged the
creation of A. Yep, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Sorry, the
solution to A transpose A?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Yeah, I see, OK.
So the reason I stopped
here was that A transpose A
will be singular.
So I wouldn't, like, go ahead,
go forward to A transpose Au=f.
But if I put on some supports,
then of course now all good.
So now I have, what's
now the shape of A?
For this one.
I now have this bar is
now, forget it, right?
This bar is just
between two supports.
So if we put it in the matrix
it'll just be a row of zeroes.
Nothing will happen,
and we're better off
to just knock it out.
So I think, now I have,
I now have four bars.
And how many unknowns?
Four: two there and two there.
And, do you guess
that it's stable?
That truss?
Yeah, that looks stable to me.
So the four by four
matrix would be invertible
and then I could solve.
Good point.
Then, A would be four
by four, A transpose
would be four by four, C would
be four by four in between.
This is the case that-- I
gave a name for this case.
When I have a square matrix,
do you remember the name just
for the hell of it?
Statically determinate.
It's determinate because each
step determines everything
completely.
Normally, if I have
another bar there,
now it would be five
by four, and now
I really have to do the A
transpose C A to get to a four
by four invertible.
By itself, A would
not be invertible.
This is the more typical
case, where you really
have to put all three together.
Right.
I hope you enjoyed the trusses
part, though, and continue
to enjoy them this evening.
OK, I'll just keep
moving to be sure
that we cover any other topics.
Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
For this matrix?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
For that truss?
Oh my God.
OK, let me see.
Then can I do one row?
OK, of course, you guys are
responsible for much more.
Alright, which row shall I do?
Which bar?
A diagonal bar?
I knew you'd make it like,
you could make up quizzes
and I could just sit back here.
OK, so let's take this
diagonal bar, alright.
And are we going to keep
that supported, or not?
Do you want to
keep it supported?
OK, so in this case then
that end is not moving.
So this will be in
this, and this bar
corresponds to a row of A.
And how many non-zeroes will
I expect in that row?
Just two.
Normally four, but I'm not
getting any motion down here.
So it'll just be two and
if that's 45 degrees,
shall we say, then that
row, I think, would be what?
Well, OK.
Where do my non-zeroes appear?
This is node number
one with an H and a V.
So I think we have zeroes.
If that bar stretches-- The
connection between displacement
and stretching of this bar
does not involve this guy.
So I think it's
zero and zero there.
And now, what else is it?
So now come the
real numbers, which
I believe to be cosine
and sine of that angle.
Because if I, how much
does that bar stretch?
I know that I'm looking
for a cosine and a sine,
and if this goes positively,
then the bar does stretch.
If this goes positively,
that does stretch the bar
so I'm expecting
positive numbers there,
like the cosine, square
root of two over two,
and the sine, square
root of two over two.
Well, I dodged the bullet
of getting the whole matrix,
but maybe that would do it.
Why don't we do
this the top one?
Yeah.
Tell me the first, if
that's bar one, what would
be the first row of the matrix?
OK, it involves
both of these nodes.
But the angle is zero.
So that's going to
be a little special.
So if this goes
out horizontally,
I should really start
with the first one.
Is this goes horizontally
it compresses the bar,
I think we get a
minus one there.
If it goes vertically,
that doesn't do anything.
If this goes horizontally
it does do something.
If it goes vertically
it doesn't.
I'd say that would be the row of
the matrix coming from the top.
That would give
me the stretching.
You remember, I'm
always going to,
I think of
multiplying this by u.
I think of multiplying that by
[u 1 H, u 1 V, u 2 H, u 2 V],
and this top row
should give me you
u 2 H minus u 1 H, which
is the stretch in bar one.
So that would be a
typical one, this
would be at least
typical of one where
I do see a cosine and a sine.
And let me just finally add,
suppose this was not supported.
OK, suppose that's
not supported,
now I've got a couple more
columns to squeeze in.
Maybe I can somehow do it here.
Can I squeeze in the
two more columns?
So can you complete the
top row of the matrix?
Now I've got six columns.
Because here's two, here's
two, here's two more.
What goes on the top
row of a matrix now?
Zeroes, because this is
not affected by bar one.
But it is affected by this bar.
So it's going to show up in this
row, and how will it show up?
Two negatives, right.
A negative cosine and a negative
sine. and at 45 degrees I
can't tell the difference.
Because if these move forward,
that compresses the bar.
So the minus sign.
So again, the rows
add up to zero,
as we expect when the bar
is not touching a support.
This is not touching a
support, so it adds up to zero.
OK, we'll have a truss
problem this evening,
but not a big messy one.
How about finite elements?
You guys, do you
like finite elements?
I'm sort of hoping to
make them attractive.
I noticed a problem, just
to give us some specific one
to work on, and I don't remember
that it was a homework problem.
This is Section 3.1, number 18,
asks about the equation u''=0.
Well, we've talked
about it in class.
With u(0)=0 but u' of-- the
slope equal zero at the other
end.
So what's the picture if
I use linear elements?
I don't remember how many
I used in the problem.
Well, it allows you to
use N interior guys, one,
two, up to N, and then
another-- This will come in.
Or that's the point.
OK, so what's the
finite element method,
finite element
matrix K for this--
So I want to do linear elements
and I want to construct K.
And, yeah, I guess.
Oh, I haven't
actually made anything
happen to this problem.
All zeroes is kind
of slow going.
u will be, the solution
will certainly be zero.
So maybe I'd better put in a
load here to get some action.
OK, well, yeah.
So I proposed this question
but now, is this a question
to think about?
I think that's a
reasonable example to do.
It's got the two types
of boundary conditions.
It's got the
right-hand side f, it's
got linear elements which means
it's kind of doable by hand.
And we kind of know what
matrix to expect out of it.
What matrix do we expect?
What do I expect out
of linear elements,
do you remember the point about
linear elements on equally
spaced meshes?
That just brought back our
regular difference matrices.
So I'm expecting
this stiffness matrix
to be a difference matrix.
Anyway, the point
of this question
is, OK, I have a hat function,
I have a hat function,
I've a hat function, a hat
function, and is that the end?
Is that the complete list
of my trial functions?
One more, right?
Because this condition is, all
my trial and test functions
don't have to satisfy this.
So I'm allowed, and should
have, another guy there.
A half hat for that one.
You may say, don't let that
clown into the finite element
space but I think it should be.
The solution won't
use much of it.
Because the solution is
going to aim for zero slope.
But it's going to need a
little-- You see why it needs
a little bit, something here?
Because this thing
has slope down.
So if there's some
of that in there,
there better be somebody
else to cancel it.
If our approximation is going
to have about zero slope.
OK, so then.
Can you construct a matrix K?
Let's see, what's
the (2,3) entry?
So if I call this number
one, this number two,
oh, I've already numbered.
So number two and number
three, so that trial
function against that one.
What do I?
What's my formula for the (2,3)
entry of the stiffness matrix?
It's some integral, right?
And what do I integrate?
I integrate, yeah.
And I've got to
have to remember.
So I do, yeah, my weak form--
I've integrated by parts,
so my weak form is the integral
of u'*v'*dx equals the integral
of f times. v dx.
That's my weak form.
I did two integrations by
parts and the integrated term
will go away.
Because of those zeroes.
OK, so K_(2,3) will come from
this side when I'm using phi_2
and phi_3, because
I'm taking the phis,
the phis and the V's both
the same hat function.
OK, so what do I get
for that? phi_2' is?
So this is it, and
it overlaps this one.
So when it overlaps this
phi_2 is coming down
and phi_3 is going up.
And the slope is 1/h, let's say.
So I think I'm integrating us a
negative slope, is that right?
Times a positive slope.
And I'm really only integrating
over one h interval.
The two overlap only here,
where this one's coming down
and that one's going up.
So I think-- dx.
And the great thing is, of
course, we have a constant.
So I have minus one
over h squared times h,
I think minus one over h.
That would be K_(2,3).
That's a simple example.
And then at the end we will
see it, we'll see this one,
I think we'll get some matrix.
We'll have this 1/h
outside, I think
we'll have something like two,
minus one; two, minus one;
minus one and then only
a one from the half-hat.
I think it would be that matrix
that would be K. I think.
Maybe with more,
greater size if we
have a whole bunch of elements.
But that pattern.
You're pretty much into this?
Yeah, I mean we're doing
a lot in this course.
I'm really grateful
you guys stay with it,
and kept to these new ideas,
through doing exercises
and so on.
Because there's a lot here.
Well, I thought I'd
put an example up,
to open up, just
to remind you what
that language is about there.
And to be ready for any
question in that topic.
Or any question whatever.
So I jumped in with
finite elements,
but I'm ready also to talk
about that area of the course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Yeah. x+iy stuff, OK.
Basically, any
function of x+iy, yeah.
Any function.
So strictly, yeah, I mean a
mathematician would say what,
any function?
That's, you've opened the door
to crazy things saying that.
So what I really mean is, we
have these powers of x+iy,
and then we have
combinations of them.
So the only requirement
would be that if I
want to take an
infinite combination
it should, the series
should, add up to something.
If it has a nice
Taylor series then
those are the best
functions there are.
Functions with
nice Taylor series.
I'll just say it.
Having used those words.
Suppose I take that function.
There's a function, that's
a function-- z is x+iy.
But z is shorter to write.
So it's not a
polynomial, obviously.
But it is a function of x+iy.
Well, tell me this.
Where does that
function go wrong?
So e^z is a function that
never goes wrong, right? e^z,
that series always converges.
Can you tell me the series, if
I expand that into a series,
what series am I looking at?
This is not on the
exam, so to speak.
Do you know one over
one plus something,
what's the series for that?
Well the constant term, when
z is zero is certainly a one.
I think the trick, it's
this is geometric series,
and because it's a
z squared it's that.
That would be the
geometric series.
With constant ratio z squared.
If I multiply that
by that, 1 plus z
squared times that,
everything will cancel
and I'll get the one.
That's it.
So there is a Taylor
series for this function.
Now, the reason I chose that
example is, you could tell me,
it doesn't converge if
z is too large, right?
Is this an analytic function?
Where is this a good
function and where does it
have problems?
If z is less than one, and I
really mean magnitude of z,
so let me draw the z-plane.
Here's the real part of z
that you usually call x,
and the imaginary part of
z that you usually call y,
because z is x+iy, and where
will this series converge?
It'll converge out as
far as this circle.
This is the Taylor
series around zero.
Right?
The constant term
I found at z=0.
Then that series, this
function, is great.
It's an analytic
function, everything,
it gives us a solution to
Laplace's-- This'll be,
the real and imaginary parts
of that will be the u and the s
that solve Laplace's equation.
Out to, at least in this circle.
But something, there's a problem
at the edge of the circle.
Now, here's my point.
If I think of one over
one plus x squared,
look at that for a minute.
That function has no
problems at all, right?
One over one plus x squared,
you can let x be anything?
It's no trouble.
But one over one
plus z squared, when
we look in the complex
plane, ah, we find a problem.
And where is the problem
with this function?
At z equals, so everybody's
looking at this guy.
There's a problem with
that function at z=i.
And it happens to
be not an accident,
it's right there on the circle.
It's hiding in the complex--
it's not on the real axis.
So the real person
didn't notice it.
But the complex person said
ah, that's the problem.
There's a singularity there, and
of course it's called a pole,
and people in so many parts of
science are interested in that.
Is there any other place
that there's a problem?
At minus i.
When z is minus i we'll
also get a problem.
So this is a function with
two poles, those two poles
and they're the reason that
the series couldn't make it.
Going out this way the series
doesn't meet any problems.
But the series always
goes out in a circle,
and the first circle, the first
guy, the first problem it hits,
the series stops converging.
By the way, let me
ask you a question.
Suppose I instead did the
Taylor series around this point?
Now, what do I mean by that?
That's the point one, let's say.
What do I mean by that, the
Taylor series around one?
I'll rewrite the function as one
plus, well now, what do I do?
I want it in z
minus one squared.
Oh, gosh.
I'm getting beyond what
you will care about.
Again, if I expanded, if I wrote
the power series in powers of z
minus one, what
would it work in?
And then I'll stop
with this example.
The circle would reach
out until it hit a pole.
And it can't make
it past that pole.
So it would be a circle of
radius square root of two,
there would be a circle there.
If we were going to
discuss, and this is really
Chapter 5 of the book.
I mention it, because you've
got a book that explains this.
If I thought the center
of the universe was there,
and then the poles
are still here,
the circle will make
it out to those poles.
So I can do Taylor series, I
can sort of hook together Taylor
series all over the place.
And they'll all quit
when they reach a pole,
but when I put all
those circles together
I can get all the
rest of the plane.
OK, so that's something
about, I don't
know how I got onto that
department, but it's amazing.
This, so the real and imaginary
parts of that would be a flow,
would give me a flow.
I don't know if it'd be
easy to compute it or not,
maybe I won't tackle that here.
But we could find
the real part of that
and the imaginary part
of that, and we would
have a genuine flow field.
Satisfying Laplace's equation
with the two orthogonal,
the streamlines orthogonal
to the equipotentials.
We could totally
do that example.
OK, let me, yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: You say one test
question is based on x+iy?
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
Well, this sort of stuff.
But, so u would be
the, yeah that's right.
Yeah, so a test question
would be something like,
one way or another, you would
end up with a u, and an s,
and the u+is, if
they're a good pair,
would be some function
of this magic z.
Yeah, yeah.
That's right.
So whatever.
We know examples, of course.
For example, this could be
x squared minus y squared.
And the s that goes
with that is 2xy,
and the function that's involved
there when I throw in the i
is simply z squared.
OK, that would be
an example where
the real and imaginary parts
of this give us the good u,
its good friend
s, and the picture
of streamlines
and equipotentials
meeting at right angles.
Just, a beautiful picture, all
coming out of this function.
So probably the quiz will
have some other function.
But you'll still have a u and
an s and a function of x+iy.
So if it's not this one,
which I don't think it is.
It won't be be this one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes.
Because first of all, I wouldn't
have mentioned it if I was.
And secondly, that's
a little too messy,
I think, to get
a good handle of,
to take the real and
imaginary parts of that.
It's not impossible, of course.
We could completely do it.
There'd be some ratio
of two polynomials.
Here we have just
simple polynomials.
OK, does that help
with that question?
Yeah.
What else is on your mind?
Any thoughts?
Yeah, thanks.
Curl, OK.
Well, so I didn't really
do three dimensions.
But curl is important.
And we did see, in two
dimensions the key fact
that all this
stuff-- Let me just
write down what the great
connections are between these.
Because I can't let
the whole semester go
without writing down that,
what is it, the grad--
Is it the curl of a gradient?
The curl of any gradient
of u is always zero.
Whatever it is.
Whatever u is.
And this comes from, let
me put the other one down
and then I'll just say why.
The other one is like the
transpose of this one.
So if I transpose, so
this is the zero operator.
Curl times gradient
gives the zero.
So if I just transpose
I still have zero.
So if it's a
transposed gradient,
I have minus divergence, and
actually if I transpose curl
I get curl again.
Of any, now I should put in,
what should the curl act on?
It acts on a w, I guess is.
No, divergence w, it
acts on an S, sorry.
OK, and the minus
sign, of course,
isn't going to matter
because I've got
a zero on the right-hand side.
So S. Yeah, so if I take any
field-- I mean this is like,
real proper vector calculus.
To check these, I call them
identities and maybe sometimes
people indicate an identity
meaning it's always
true for every u,
or for every S.
They'll use the
triple equals sign.
Just to say they're
really equal.
OK, so we could define the curl,
but you've met it elsewhere
and maybe this isn't
the time to do that.
What's the key fact, the
key little math business
that makes all these true?
So there's sort of a formal
math fact that makes them true.
And then there's the
physical understanding
of gradients being directions
out with no rotation.
So the physical
understanding of that.
But the math, the
formal math fact
is the fact that the second
derivative of u with respect
to x and y is equal to what?
It's equal to second derivative
with respect to y and x, yep.
So you would find if you
wrote out all the terms here,
or all the terms here,
you would find that
just by using that fact,
they all cancel each other.
And the book, of
course, does that.
So we simply didn't do 3-D in
the vector calculus section.
So I'll stop there with
that, because it's really
saying that the curl is
tremendously important.
It measures vorticity and flow,
and it's-- Being able to-- You
know that like, you take
the Navier-Stokes equations?
Well, the pressure and
the velocity are the,
I'd say primary variables
or the natural quantities
to measure, pressure and
velocity for a fluid flow.
But you could also use
these identities to set up
in terms of other variables.
Just rewrite the equation
and you get other things.
Mentioning Navier-Stokes and
fluid flow reminds me to say,
we keep using the example
of Laplace's equation.
And a person could say wait
a minute, get beyond that.
Right?
So why are you always, when
you teach finite elements,
why do you always start
with Laplace's equation?
OK, well the main reason
is it's the simplest one.
It's the one where you can
really see what's happening.
More complicated
equations would be for,
like, elasticity, plane
elasticity, or 3-D elasticity
or other boundary value
problems could be quite messy.
But Laplace's equation is
not totally a waste of time.
First, it comes up when you
have these scalar unknowns.
And then it also comes
up in numerical methods
for Navier-Stokes.
So the standard numerical
method for Navier-Stokes,
which would come
in 18.086, ends up
with Laplace's equation
for the pressure.
So to have a fast Laplace
solver, as in today's lecture,
pays off.
So I'm just saying
Laplace's equation
is important in itself,
it has the great advantage
of being the simplest example
we could possibly think of.
It's the example where
an x+iy trick works.
And it actually comes up in
serious big computations,
because the equation
for the pressure
comes out to be a Laplace
or a Poisson equation.
Now.
I kept going there.
Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: We
did, as a MATLAB problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Sorry?
And a first order, right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Huh.
Yeah.
I would do it the same way
but it wouldn't be symmetric,
of course.
That was the point about
that convection term,
is-- The diffusion term would
be just what we've done, right?
The diffusion term was
that second derivative.
And what would it
look like in, as long
as we're close to, what would
convection-diffusion in 2-D
look like?
Just, I mean part
of your interest
is pass 18.085 and
get rid of it, right?
But another part is
like, these are problems
that if you're in Course
16, Course 2, others,
you're going to meet this.
So the diffusion
part is going to be,
again in 2-D I'll have
some minus u, well,
I made it simple because
I took c(x) to be one.
It could have a c(x) in there.
And what would the
convection term look like?
I'd have a velocity, in
the x direction, say a V_x.
And a velocity in
the y direction, V_y.
V_y times-- That's
just a number.
In the simplest case that
would be my river is traveling,
or my flow is traveling
along, and equals zero.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Sorry?
Yeah I don't know which way the
river's traveling, actually.
So those are just constants.
They could have positive
or negative signs.
The V_x and V_y is the
constant flow that's carrying,
what am I doing here?
The flow is flowing along,
and if those are constants
it's just flowing
steady, steady flow.
But it's diffusing
at the same time.
And this would bring in
that same difficulties
that we met in the MATLAB 1-D.
So the MATLAB 1-D problem just
didn't have a y.
I don't care, yeah the
sign I'm not worried about,
it's just is that
there, now I'm in 2-D.
And what would I expect to see?
I'd expect to see some
trouble when V is large.
When V is large, convection,
this is convection down here.
This is the convection part.
And if V is large, then so that
this should be a lower order
term, is really fighting
against this higher order term.
I expect numerical difficulties,
just the way we met.
So anyway, if I did a MATLAB
example, stretched it to 2-D
we see a whole lot
of interesting stuff.
We'd see flow in,
flow out, yeah.
But I just can't do everything.
But that would have a weak
form, but your question
about weak forms,
weak form, when
you have this
anti-symmetric term
for odd number of derivatives,
is not quite as beautiful.
But you have to deal
with it, of course.
Yep.
OK, Ready for whatever.
Any thoughts?
Let's see, just
have a look again
at the list of problem topics.
To see if anything
occurs to you.
I mean, not that it should.
You know we're OK.
I'm happy to call
it a day on that,
and time for dinner for
everybody and see you at 7:30.